hello in today's cloud minute I'll be
demonstrating how to get help with G
cloud G cloud us the command line tool
that you use to access and configure
your Google cloud platform resources if
you are ever unsure how to use a g-cloud
command just type the command followed
by - - help this gives you some basic
information about how to use the command
for example this page says to use
g-cloud followed by a group and then a
command and if I scroll down a little
bit I can see the different groups that
I can use with the g-cloud command one
group pretty much everyone uses this can
fake here's what the help looks like for
config and here you can see that the
possible commands was config our list
set and unset if I want to know how to
use the list command I can type G cloud
config list - - help the help page says
that there's a - - all option that will
show me all the different properties
that I can set with G cloud config so
let's look at that
and now you can see all the different
properties that you can set with g-cloud
config so if you're ever confused or
stuck when using g-cloud try out the
built-in hump thanks for watching please
check out some of our other cloud minute
videos